those Recon phantoms is an online game
the community is the lifeblood of what
we do we have no community who may as
well just all pack up and flip burgers
tomorrow do something else the community
is the game there would be no client
competition there will be no friends
list there would be no camaraderie no
rivalry if you didn't have people to
love and hate most of the story in the
experience comes from their interaction
with each other their relationship with
each other and things go wrong the
community of the first bunch of people
that can give us visibility on exactly
what is happening how their experience
has been impacted if their ranking
version one was an interesting challenge
for us it was our first attempt to
creating player leaderboards but the
outcome was this actually had unforeseen
circumstances the slightest mistake is
an immediate impact and an extremely
long term memory people remember you for
what you've done so one of the things is
i will say hi to those guys on the forum
thanks for digging up all those pets you
know it's putting them together in force
the fina rank really taught us that we
need to spend more time engaging with
our community before pushing out a
feature that might impact users behavior
so I would argue that perhaps this
feature went out a little bit early
we've learnt ready to begin engaging
Athena Council the Athena Council is
composed of both the developers and
select few gamers who interact with each
other on a regular basis to share ideas
to share feedback the purpose of
improving the game I think they're that
what we see when our gamers are
frustrated is just their passion for the
game and I really appreciate that and
it's something that just lets me know
that they really enjoy the game or else
it wouldn't feel so strongly about it so
playing with the players really did help
me better understand their needs in
terms of what is the competitive scene
look like what are the demands for
equipment you need to bring any the
competitive scene I have met one player
in your life in Kuala Lumpur that was a
lot of fun three of us went up there and
we got to say how I made up a lot of
gamers have become my friends actually
in fact them if I do travel to countries
where they are residing I look forward
to having some drinks and dinner with
them and meeting them in person
you